twenty-four US senators planned to
attend this morning's memorial service
in Phoenix for Senator John McCain
former Vice President Joe Biden will
give one of the eulogies an estimated 12
to 15 thousand people lined up to view
McCain's casket at the Arizona State
Capitol yesterday South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham offered a rare emotional
reflection yesterday on the death of his
friend that we haven't seen before
we spoke with Graham about their unique
relationship that spanned more than two
decades he talked about the pain of
losing his friends the more surprising
moments of McCain's life and their last
moments together we've heard a lot about
Senator McCain this week what's
something people would be surprised to
learn about John McCain how kind he was
how did that manifest its own paying
tremendous amount of tension when you
needed it the most that he could be a
handful they could rip your head off all
on and on and on but he could be
incredibly kind just by picking up the
phone making sure that you knew he was
there for you what would he say if he
was calling you now look up knock that
crap
you're embarrassing here do you still
have the instinct to take out your phone
and call them as people ask me what
what's it like yes I literally yesterday
afternoon I literally almost picked up
my phone so I don't know who in your
life that you talked to about business
matters or almost share things with
about your hopes and your dreams and you
know your business activities it was
John for me if you can't talk to him
what do you hear him sing in your head
it's steady
keep pushing be careful but steady stay
involved don't give up
did you get a chance to say goodbye to
him yeah I did and when I walked in he
just smiled and held my hand but really
say anything and Friday was a bad day
but yeah some told me to go I was
planning to go this week and I found a
hole of my schedule sister I need to go
what did you tell him when you when you
say goodbye you did good you exceeded
every expectation your dad your
grandfather had for you you did right by
your country did right by your friends
and I am better for having met you and
he just squeezed really hard you
traveled all over the world together yes
every place no one else wanted to go
yeah
you were never anywhere very long this
man John McCain had more energy than ten
men the doctor told me you in Sydney
that he had eight times the tolerance
for pain of the average person but he
had a schedule that would literally kill
you but he was curious last question
we're sitting in the Russell Senate
office building should it be the John
McCain son yes bill I think we need a I
don't know I need the Capitol after the
guy and be John McCain DC I want to see
what the family thinks
but the Capitol Visitor Center he hated
that place it turned out to be marvelous
what if it's the first thing you saw was
the life of John McCain what if it was
the John McCain Capitol Visitor Center
that would be perfect in this regard it
would be an educational moment for young
people to know that men like John McCain
existed then they'll find out about
other men and women that made this place
truly great and it would annoy the hell
out of it
so it'd be my way of getting back thank
you thank you he was he went the range
of emotions yesterday thinking about
John McCain and that and those final
times holding his hand and and and and
that when he said that he he still
reaches for his phone to call him you
know they would call each other
constantly all day long you know Lindsey
Graham has been very supportive of
President Trump and we know McCain was
not close with President Trump did that
cause a rift at all between them well we
talked about that yes there was a lot of
clashes and his argument is what did
John McCain do he made up with George
Bush and Barack Obama about who John
McCain said some extraordinarily bitter
things but in the end he made up with
them and what Lindsey Graham said is
that's my job is even though I disagree
this president and he talked about the
all the presidents flaws but he said
John McCain's message was that you got
to serve your country by doing what you
can to work with the president there are
obviously some people who believe that
serving John McCain's memory means
keeping up constant resistance against
the president interesting